come with me as I poop in New Zealand's
most photographed public toilet located
in kawakawa near the top of the North
Island the hundraser toilets are the
final and only southern hemisphere
project from reclusive artist freeden
shrike hungerer he was an artist who
rejected straight lines rationalism
function and flat surfaces an uneven
floor he said is a Melody to the feet to
him sterile industrial standards and
prohibitions against personalizing one
space were forms of incarceration he saw
the human mind as a guest in nature so
in these toilets were built he asked
that all the vegetation that used to
populate the lot be planted on the roof
and hundraser loved feces in fact he
wrote an entire Manifesto called The
Holy sh to him there is no such thing as
waste to honor this philosophy I left a
fresh offering because we call the rich
organic life-giving component of soil
that's made of death and poop and pee
worked over by microorganisms humus and
from the same route comes what we call
ourselves humans